they paid their respects to Britain's
Queen and she honored the memory of
Ireland's dead two heads of state
stripped silently shoulder to shoulder
in the Garden of Remembrance I think
even if the Queen had calm say ten years
ago I think there were things she
couldn't have done them and one of those
was laying a wreath at the Garden of
Remembrance which is is there to
remember people who violently rebels
against the British Empire I don't think
she could have done that ten years ago
even though the peace process was
underway it was still a bit too raw it's
90 years since the Irish parted company
with the British in a violent uprising
Her Majesty acknowledged those who had
rebelled against the crime in their
pursuit of independence it would be
difficult if not impossible to overstate
the significance of this simple ceremony
just one act of reconciliation but a
defining moment in the history of these
islands few thought they'd ever see the
Queen standing on ground that is sacred
elephants the royal couple will have
limited opportunity to meet the public
during their tour the vast majority of
people are glad to see them but there
are dissenting voices
I don't see any problem with the
language yeah leaving the cast at the
past and maybe we should get over what
happened and make these colliders see
her here is very welcome and hopefully
our histories will be reconciled
security could not have been tighter
it's costing 30 million euro to protect
the Queen dissident Republicans opposed
to the peace process have demonstrated
capability and threatened to cause
disruption Her Majesty has become the
first British monarch to touch down in
the independent state
the Republic didn't exist when her
grandfather George v visited Dublin
essentially ago President Mary McAleese
has built bridges her residents provided
the backdrop for a ceremonial welcome
it's a punishing schedule Dublin Kildare
Tipperary
Cork all in the space of four days there
will be other symbolic gestures this
week but none more striking than the
first britain's sovereign has recognized
Ireland's independence and the Republic
has extended the hand of friendship